ma liberté aujourd'hui vous voyez elle
est là c'est 30 cm de câbles et trois
kilos de matériel que je porte n 4
heures sur 24 jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours on se croit revenu sous le régime
de vichy je suis rentré dans deux
chambres dans ce service de réanimation
de corbeil-essonnes dans la première
chambre il y avait un jeune homme de 28
ans de 28 ans en coma intubé et ventilé
avec pas loin de 10 pouces seringue pour
pouvoir à la fois l'alimenter fournir
les médicaments essentiels pour le
maintenir en vie dans la deuxième
chambre il y avait un homme en surpoids
âgé de 35 ans c'est ça la réalité madame
des blessés de médiathèque et
bourg-lès-valence en totalité elle est
là la qualité des hôpitaux à l'ena la
réalité des hôpitaux
c'est à l'arrière les ténors deux
hôpitaux
en train de débattre de ce sujet alors
que le soignant se battre contre les
débits de cette manière-là d'hôpitaux
surtout une annonce de votre
gouvernement a dernièrement choqué
profondément le pays vous prévoyez à
partir du 1er octobre de baisser de 5
euros par mois le montant des
allocations logement après les retraités
les fonctionnaires les smicards nous
attaquer maintenant les plus pauvres
cela concerne 6,7 millions de nos
concitoyens les plus modestes les plus
fragiles
76% des ménages se situant dans les 10 %
la population française la plus pauvres
touchés apn avez vous calculez
d'ailleurs le nombre de pauvres
supplémentaires que vous allez fabrique
5 euros c'est une somme qui permet de se
nourrir pendant quelques jours beaucoup
de personnes j'ai fait les courses ce
matin à monsieur le premier ministre
elles sont là et voilà ce que vous
supprimez tous les mois par les plus
démunis le président mélenchon vous le
monde elles sont à votre disposition est
aussi à la disposition de la députée au
petit voilà en même temps monsieur le
ministre
votre politique c'est apprendre en plus
preuve et rendre plus riches l'article 2
ans l'état est un monstre juridique
c'est un monstre juridique jusqu'au fond
on réinvente ce qu'on appelait au 19e
siècle les classes sociales dangereuse
ouvriers la présomption de culpabilité
et ce texte est fondamentalement anti
constitutionnel puisque une autorité
administrative va priver un individu de
sa liberté de circulation et de
manifester au motif qu'il ya une
présomption on va lui interdire un des
raisons sérieuses de penser qu'ils
apprécient de raisons sérieuses
l'autorité administrative au ballon
aussi de penser que son comportement
constitue une menace d'une particulière
gravité politique mais où sommes-nous
mes chers collègues mais c'est la dérive
complète
on se croit revenu sous le régime de
vichy mais oui mais oui mes chers
collègues oui oui je dis bien le régime
de vichy mais oui il ya vous êtes
présumé un par votre attitude est
possible est résistant donc on vous en
taule voilà par l'autorité
administrative
mais où sommes-nous mais réveillez vous
mes chers collègues chaque collègue
attention on est en train de parler d'un
sujet qui a fait 130 mille morts qui a
fait des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui comme moi et vous savez
par quelles étapes je suis passé comme
moi vont devoir vivre jusqu'à la fin de
leurs jours avec les conséquences du coc
vide donc aujourd'hui on est en train de
parler de comment est ce qu'on met tout
en oeuvre pour éviter que ça arrive
alors on peut parler liberté on peut on
peut prendre la liberté dans tous les
sens mais la liberté ce n'est pas un
ensemble de droits c'est un ensemble de
devoirs et un ensemble de droits c'est
un équilibre juste entre les droits et
les devoirs ma liberté aujourd'hui voyez
elle est là c'est 30 cm de câbles et
trois kilos de matériel que je porte 24
heures sur 24
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours c'est ça la
réalité c'est la mienne et c'est celle
de dizaines de milliers de personnes
dans ce pays dont la vie a été
bouleversée par une épidémie rappels au
règlement
monsieur la salle briller immédiatement
retiré ce gilet
orfèvres sur la salle ce rappel au
règlement sera évidemment inscrire
procès verbal et vous en subirez les
conséquences
retirer s'il vous plaît ce gilet
sur la salle
[Musique]
monsieur la salle s'il vous plaît allez
manifester hors de cet hémicycle
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
la séance est suspendue